giorno 4 del blog mas concrete per te la
mattina così un mostro ancora di sono
venuto a darmi una mano per costruire
questo nuovo castello che vorrà dire che
dovrò sacrificare e farlo finalmente da
solo senza di palla al piede poi jam e
jam e poi io non andrò tipo a dire ciao
ragazzi che bello vedere di riassetto
sempre spetta di prendere in giro ma ci
sei solo tu buon salve ragazzi ma enrico
alone pervenuto ci sono resi conto aver
fatto un errore praticamente il terzo
libro ci si può lavorare in 22 enne
fisseremo loro che lavorano non curanti
noi egoiste egoist assistiti vedo quanto
lo volete trovare questo modo si
dobbiamo dare una soluzione a stanno già
stanno giocando solo loro e loro non è
che c'è loro proprio egoiste nell'anima
loro ragazzi stiamo andando alla grande
ma poi ragazzi possiamo dire una
cosa abbiamo lasciato la roba giulia
imprecisa se fosse stata costruita da
loro che sarà la camera dei segreti cioè
una lucertola vendita è partito il così
se partita il dibattito a questo qui
secondo voi che gianmarco volete che
gianmarco dice che si apre nel senso che
è attaccato con questi cosini che si
possono abbassare tipo così ok ma
secondo voi questa è la capanna di
hagrid con la camera dei segreti
no perché
aragon delle zucche beh sì sì già marco
dice che la camera dei segreti di aver
cambiato dal sesso perché per questo in
cui amo romantici poi questo qui per
loro ieri era il pensatoio la confisca
successo io adesso ritorno capo
costruttore perché non accetto questa
dominio due donne alla costruzione di
awards mentre noi siamo a fissarli
bellissimo comunque della piramide va
filtrata annuncia come mai si legga
giulia se vedi che non si attaccano usa
l'attaccante rione san marco san marco e
dove era nel tuo
ecco ecco dove va la capanna di hagrid
della camera dei segreti
ecco hanno perso hanno perso un pezzo
hanno perso un pezzo un pezzo ha perso
dai che l'hai trovato le trovato
qualsiasi allarmismo faccia alla nostra
pioggia per far o comunque ad essere
impaziente abbiamo dato al daltonico il
compito per i daltonici di riconoscere
le perline dove stanno le perline valide
le perline trasparenti gialle azzurre di
tutti i colori del mondo vede che però
per riduzioni da ragazzi per un
daltonico e terribile che attraverso la
ripulsa paneuropei
ecco le schiere la scacchiera e la
scacchiera della scacchiera
guardate ci stanno le chiavi
la stanza della pineta fine eccole oggi
tosse e andremo a questa roba qui e cosa
vede le brave a una scuola che cosa il
tranello ventina voli no stop montando
poi qui odio pardo gravissime dai è
ininterrottamente siamo io e lei
certo le sere il progetto del
progetto inoltre oricola all'area felici
di farlo qui che cos'è non l'abbia
rimani fantasmi divinazione astra voleva
un'altra opzione oppure no ma non è arte
oscure art e arti oscure arthaus curia
anna magnani mangiarvi leggo grazie
comunque il 5 di droga stress mangiare
uccide un momento di pausa abbiamo
beccato penne siamo rubati ha invitato a
mangiare a forza con noi
che fai adesso ora tornerai giocherai è
tanto vero anch'io come non detto devo
fare una cosa di di lavoro quindi adesso
io dovrò andarmene anche di chi se ne
torneranno a casa monta il castello il
castello il cartello in tremato rosico
perché penso che cosa stanno facendo
loro in questo momento a casa adesso in
sua assenza
mara venier emo tutti i piani a
cominciare da questo sono qui in uno
studio legale più piccoli sempre enea
per quella mia cugina e come ci sono
altri tuoi soci nel sacco nel mondo dei
vincenti si dice soci cioè ci si parla
come soci ok va bene a me interessa
invece il mio pacco che il mondo degli
influenzati invece ed è un matto chi è
arrivato questo si possa fare lo zoom
con questo cosa primi parco si no
[Risate]
ma che cazzo mattino
se c'è qualcosa di vivo perché la
moresca classe la borsa permetterci
delle cose che sono le cose che tu non
riporterà i a casa perché rimarranno qui
ad arredare questo bellissimo studio ma
non ci riesco a riprendere bellissime
sono meravigliose non mi azzardo più a
fare quei finti giu man mano che cos'è
non lo so ma fa che è bellissimo
e so anche che rimarrà qui questo
solamente al sole sole oggi non senso le
tirate raggi uva che fanno i raggi uva
come fai carina ma chi è quella
bellissima ragazza leggera e c'è chi
tocca fare l'albero di natale sei triste
farmi la faccia di sadness questo ormai
siano totalmente licenziato dal cassetto
io non c'entro più zia è finito il
castello non volevo anche cosi cosa
[Risate]
a tutto gas libico a chiave ecco come il
temibile un sostenete tuoi fan potatori
dei tuoi soci che hanno distrutto
lungaro spinato ballo composto della
fascia vogliono far volare il progetto
corrivi e hitachi e zoppo nel set d
motivo mi manchi un pezzo
però almeno adesso dobbiamo risolvere io
direi che ci siamo avvicinati più o meno
al risultato finale
meglio non potevano fare i fantastici
alta questo è il platano
abbiamo dovuto usare il piede siccome si
chiama per ultimarlo siamo andati a
prendere la cioccolata con mia cugina e
si io non sono a dieta e mi ha scritto
un'altra nostra cucina c'è scritto
dicendo che stanno facendo delle cose
orribili al castello di hogwarts hanno
montato al posto della testa della testa
del drago di bombe co quindi la b è
stato bellissimo ma devo ammettere che
casca cause di forza e mazzarri dei
ragionamenti in altri poteri derivano
grandi responsabilità
come dice mettimi piante biotech e
comunque non sembri minuscola sono mica
siamo un po il terrore persone
[Musica]
arrivate ma che figata
ma dagli unioni e poi che cosa avete
fatto ma la testa c'è stato un
inconveniente con che cosa le torri sono
tutte si si sa mai che cosa abbiamo
attaccato che cosa no ancora non è
attaccato sono tipo le 3 di notte
vogliamo uscire da tempo ma in compagini
[Risate]
lo sai che ha cantato tutto il tempo
ragazzi noi ponte temi la montagna da un
marco enrico asus ma che si accendo è
giusto e vero ha realmente di posizione
e personaggi e li ha piazzato due mesi
di ritardo dai the nightmare poi dovevo
stare con oltre due anni
noi ragazzi ci vediamo sempre domani
alle 14 con un altro l'opas e la mercè
di natale